mais mélenchon macro c'est plus
compliqué que le pen mélenchon je pense
que mélenchon à condition qu'il précise
son plan à il a au moins le mérite par
rapport à macron d'essayer de sortir du
statu quo alors le problème vous venez
de le dire c'est qui les plus forts sur
le plan b la sortie que sur le plan et
donc moi je pense c'est ça le principal
problème c'est que mélenchon il dit il
faut menacé tout le monde de sortie si
jamais on n'obtient pas ce qu'on veut
pourquoi pas mais à condition d'être
très clair sur ce qu'on veut obtenir et
le problème c'est que le plan à de
mélenchon moi je comprends pas en
particulier quelle est la gouvernance
démocratique qui propose pour l'europe
on dirait que parce que d'un côté il
propose la 6ème république la
démocratisation et c'est en direct sa
vision de la démocratie ça s'arrête à la
frontière du rhin c'est à dire que dès
lors qu'on parle d'europe
là ces chefs d'état contre chefs d'état
et c'est mélenchon tout seul avec merkel
qui va faire l'harmonisation fiscale un
nouvel impôt sur le sujet sauf qu'en
fait c'est le droit du bundestag de
l'assemblée nationale de voter l'impôt
donc qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire tous
les deux ils vont ils vont se mettre
ensemble d'accords sûr sur une nouvelle
europe juste un impôt sur les sociétés
et hop après les parlements nationaux
on va leur retirer le droit de voter
l'impôt ils vont renoncer à leurs
demandes m'enfin ça tient pas là moi
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment ça
marche
mélenchon finalement il ya besoin ben je
dis il ya besoin de préciser le pl aura
donc moi sur mélenchon macron je pense
que je je je veux très je veux très
clairement pour mélenchon mais un
soutien vigilant qui serait d'abord un
soutien pour pour essayer de remplir ce
plan a est de faire en sorte que la
majorité à la majorité futur ne soit pas
là pour tout faire exploser l'europe
mais sois là pour vraiment mais alors
vraiment le choix sur la table